smartphones that won't break the bank
these days that's kind of unheard of but
now apple and samsung have both created
models that are a little more
budget-friendly you can say rich
tomorrow has a comparison in techsmart
[Music]
for about 400 dollars you can have one
of these the samsung a53 5g or the
iphone se
both are new this year and have some
features typically associated with top
of the line phones
iphone sc has apple's latest and most
powerful mobile chip inside so it can
handle power hungry apps the samsung
might be a bit slower but it's fine for
everyday use
both phones have a fingerprint sensor to
unlock but samsung's is slicker since
it's under the screen and about these
screens the iphone is a tiny 4.7 inches
and the design feels dated with big
borders on the top and bottom at 6.5
inches samsung's screen feels more roomy
modern and spacious one major difference
the camera setup the iphone has just one
lens on back which means zoom is digital
and you can't take ultra wide shots the
samsung has multiple camera lenses on
back including ultra wide and macro but
zooming is still digital here's a
standard shot on iphone and on samsung
here's a low light shot on the iphone
and on samsung here's a macro shot on
the samsung which isn't possible on the
iphone here's what digital zoom looks
like on the iphone and the samsung and
an ultra wide on the samsung finally
here's a selfie on the iphone and the
samsung
both phones work with 5g networks and
have the same level of water resistance
the iphone se supports wireless charging
the samsung does not however samsung
does have a slot for a memory card which
means you can add extra storage i'm rich
demuro and you
are tech smart